I'm Alexander Rich. I'm going to tell you about experiments
that occurred during the early years of molecular biology.
I was a postdoctoral fellow with Linus Pauling from
1949-1954, and during that period, at the end of it, he asked me
to take x-ray diffraction photographs of DNA. The method for
doing this is quite simple. DNA is usually a dry fibrous material,
you moisten it with water and put it on a glass slide. The
glass slide is put on a microscope bed and attached to the
objective lens, you have a small thin glass rod. And using
the drive of the microscope, you lower the glass rod
till it touches this little gel-like material, and then you slowly
withdraw it. And at the end, you're left with a glassy looking
fiber. Since DNA is very elongated, you hope to have the molecules
parallel to each other. And using x-rays, which are simply
short wavelength light waves, but with wavelengths in the range
of the distance between atoms. You get a diffraction pattern
and from that you can infer something about the structure
of the molecule. Rosalind Franklin working in England carried out
a very wonderful experiment in which she withdrew a fiber
which was highly oriented and played an important role in allowing
Watson and Crick to propose their double stranded model
of DNA, in which the two strands are coiled around each other
with the bases flat in the middle. The bases are what we call
complementary, that is adenine pairs with thymine, and guanine
pairs with cytosine. These bases stack on each other in the
center. When I started working, the Watson and Crick paper was
published. And I could immediately see that this was correct.
And I then asked myself the following question at a meeting at Caltech,
where all the DNA people were there. I asked myself, what about
RNA? In RNA, you have the same four bases, except the
thymine which pairs with adenine, is usually replaced by uracil.
But again, complementary. So after this meeting, I started
working with RNA samples. Withdrawing fibers to see if I could get
an oriented pattern. Jim Watson, who was at Caltech at the same time,
was interested in the problem, so we worked together on this.
And during a good part of 1954, we photographed a large number
of RNA preparations that we obtained from different people.
All of them were frustrating, they did not show evidence
of orientation. And so we could not say whether it could form a
double helix or not. At the end of 1954, I went to NIH to
set up my own lab and continued working on this problem.
Around that time, methods were made, enzymes were isolated
namely by Severo Ochoa and Marianne Grunberg-Manago, which
isolated an enzyme which would take ribonucleotides and polymerize
them into chains. So you could make polyriboadenylic acid
and polyribouridylic acid. I studied these compounds
together with David Davies, who would join me at NIH.
And we found they had very little organization within them.
But in early 1956, for reasons that were not very clear to me,
I decided to mix together polyriboadenylic acid and polyribouridylic
acid. Immediately I noted that the gel became rather cloudy
and much more viscous. And so I put the glass fiber in and
carefully withdrew a fiber of the nucleic acid. And put it in
the x-ray beam, and to my astonishment, there was the diffraction
pattern of the double helix. Not the DNA double helix, a slightly different
form. And we then carried out several analyses of this, and what we
concluded was that the molecules had found each other
and combined to hybridize. The word "hybridization" was
not used at that time. It was used later, but it was meant to
describe the binding together of complementary oligonucleotides.
Complementary either DNA or RNA. So, all of a sudden,
we wrote up a short article or letter to the Journal of the American
Chemical Society describing this remarkable event. That there were two
issues here, 1. Could RNA form a double helix? The answer
was definitively yes. 2. This remarkable phenomenon
of the hybridization, or spontaneous formation, of a double helix
from individual complementary chains. Many people were very skeptical
of that interpretation. Partly they said, look, these chains are very long,
they're likely to get entangled. How would they untangle and combine?
And these chains are all negatively charged, they have phosphate
groups in them. How could those negative charges come together?
And finally, 3. An argument concerning thermodynamics. In general,
things do not go from disordered to ordered. They go from
order to disorder. How could this occur? Well, what was not obvious
to everybody, but became obvious to me after studying it,
is that the people who made these arguments did not understand
the entropic, the randomization, associated with shedding
water molecules from these chains when they combined.
Now what drives the phenomenon? What drives the phenomenon
is the fact that these bases, adenine and uracil, or guanine and
cytosine, they are essentially lipid soluble, they like to live in oils
not in water, because of their flat ring surface. So what happens
is you bring these together, forming a molecule, a double stranded
molecule which is essentially oily in the middle. And that's a very strong
force for bringing them together. Around that time in 1956,
there was a meeting in Baltimore of the McCollum Pratt dealing with genetics.
And I presented this material. And at the end of my talk, a
middle-aged Englishman in a tweed suit came up to me
and said, "Professor Rich, I want to congratulate you. You've
discovered molecular sex." This was Julian Huxley, a
science writer with a very vivid imagination. And it was his way of
describing the specificity of hybridization. The hybridization
has become a major tool in the development of molecular
biology. For example, a well-known reaction called the polymerase
chain reaction, in which you put together a system and essentially
increase the amount of DNA starting from very little. This makes
possible all kinds of medical and biological experiments. It is
based on the combination of a single strand of DNA with a
complementary small primer of 20 nucleotides or so. That
combination occurs spontaneously because of hybridization.
And it allows the whole process to continue. It's very difficult
to underestimate the extent to which hybridization dominates
a great deal of the developments that have been at the basis
of molecular biology. They're used extensively and are used broadly.
And are still so today. Thank you.